hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
and ah
[Music]
i'm just checking in on you
i'm just swinging by to see how you're
doing
that's all i'm doing
i'm not poking my head into your world
to promote my own stuff bill byrne
atlantic city next week
um i came by under the goodness of my
heart
because i care about you and i want to
make sure you're living your best
life
people is it me
not to use a a stand-up setup from 30
years ago is it me
or is there a lot of [ __ ] clothing
out there that has like life advice on
it
like self-help
you know
like live fiercely
you know i was walking by this park
today and down on the ground
the bottom of like this little [ __ ]
uh
i don't know what you call it like a
jersey barrier
down by ground where like a homeless guy
would pass out it says love life
first of all i don't like the [ __ ]
tone of that
love life
it's like [ __ ] you
you know
who are you to tell me what to do i mean
that's how [ __ ] up i am that's how i
look at it i just don't like i don't
like the tone of it you could say it a
lot more politely
you know
if you have the time take a moment to
try and love life
and then you wrote it down there where
some homeless guy is going to be for
some homeless vet or something's gonna
be [ __ ] sleeping love life you're
outside
just how like oh i just feel like it's
uh
i just feel like it's self-serving
you know like i just think a [ __ ] ego
maniac wrote it like a narcissist wrote
it
like
they have they have
you know they got everything all figured
out i know i'm going super negative on
this and i don't give a [ __ ]
it's like shut the [ __ ] up
like what [ __ ] world are you living
in
all right you just even there's people
out there that are like clinically
depressed there's nothing they can
[ __ ] do about it then you walk around
with your dumbass shirt
love life
you know i mean can you imagine that
just walk around clinically depressed
and you got to sit there and make peace
with the higher power that why they
decided to give you that brain
with whatever that leak is in the
chemicals that go into your [ __ ]
brain and you gotta walk around with
these people with this stupid ass
[ __ ] t-shirts
you know like what i love about it is
anybody can buy the [ __ ]
the shirt
so you don't you don't have to like
prove
that you're loving life or prove that
you've figured out life that you now
uh have gained some sort of uh um i
don't know what
credibility to give people advice which
i do on my podcast all the time all
right i'm full of [ __ ] it just it irks
me
and i'm actually you wouldn't know it
from this podcast
i really am enjoying my life probably
for the first time
in a long i don't know
since back when i was a kid and all the
[ __ ] happened right
i actually uh yeah kind of cut all the
cancers out
facing my own [ __ ] ugliness and
figuring that [ __ ] out and i'm actually
enjoying myself
and i'm working it out and i don't need
you chiming in with your [ __ ] stupid
t-shirt
i actually took pictures of this stupid
[ __ ] one of those
embrace life
it's just so open-ended
it just it's just i just i just that's
what it is i just think it's it's sp
it's they're not trying to help you
they're advertising that they're at
peace that's what i feel it is and it's
like no you're not if you were at peace
you wouldn't feel the need to do that
and all you're really doing is just
walking around like how like how [ __ ]
dumb do you think i am like i'm walking
around
you know not loving life and then i just
read love life oh yeah that's right i
forgot
if people aren't loving life it's not
because they don't know not to love life
probably a lot of painful [ __ ] happened
to it and they're trying to work their
way through it and your stupid [ __ ]
t-shirt it's just gonna irritate them
like it's doing to me
um
so i went on this walk this morning
so i could love life and listen to the
birds chirping
i wasn't i wasn't listening to nature i
have this [ __ ] playlist called clive
burr
which is just all iron maiden when he
was in the band
and uh
just incredible drumming so i was
listening to uh
you know
rumor and the rumor
you know some of the deeper cuts right
to the [ __ ] classics
like i mean a prisoner jesus christ what
a [ __ ] intro
you know
i don't know so anyway
so i guess cam newton's gone i guess is
what i'm trying to say cam newton is
gonna go somewhere else
and uh
and now we got mac jones so we'll we
will see how that is going to play out
um
what else i've been watching all of
these i've been watching a bunch of good
[ __ ] i watched uh
i'm still continuing on with the uh the
untouchable series
and i'm telling you the un the original
was the law and order
of back in the day where all of these
people that got their starts as actors
like my generation and i don't know how
many generations
so many people got that your first tv
credit acting tv credit being on law and
order
and i'm telling i just saw robert
redford
a young robert redford
um ed asner carol o'connor
um
charles bronson
lee
marvin um
i i brought this up on the on the last
one
how many people i've seen on that but ad
ed uh what's his face
um
jesus christ what the [ __ ] is wrong with
my brain i already forgot the goddamn
name
robert redford
uh oh man he played a piece of [ __ ] and
he did a great job
so it's an incredible series i watched
that and then i watched airplane i taped
airplane the movie which is just as
funny as it's always been
one of my favorite jokes i'd totally
forgotten about is when you first see
leslie nielsen
and you know when the first passengers
get sick and they go is there a doctor
is there a doctor and this woman goes i
think he's a doctor and she leans into
the aisle and you don't see leslie yet
she goes excuse me she goes are you a
doctor and he looks at her and he goes i
am and he's wearing a stethoscope and
he's got it in his ears
it's such a
it's such a silly stupid joke
and me and my lovely wife were sitting
there watching that
movie just laughing our asses off
um
and and what's his face uh
robert stack
just crushed it
absolutely
[ __ ] crushed it where he's just
sitting there going uh keep her at 34
000.
no feet
[Music]
it's just pound for pound i'm trying to
think of a [ __ ] those zucker brother
movies you can't cram any more jokes in
there it's just one
j that's when the [ __ ] hit the fan
all of that stuff wow looks like i
picked the wrong week to sniff to stop
sniffing glue it's still just as funny
as it always was and i was watching it
with my wife and there's nothing
i love more than listening to my wife
laugh i love listening to her laugh and
she's had such a great sense of humor
she's got a silly
sense of humor just uh like i do and i
just we just sat there
laughing our asses off watching that
movie
um
it's just oh my god just such an
incredible movie and then the other
night before that my wife started
watching the real housewives of new york
and i just i just can't get into that
one
i like the real housewives of potomac
but then once they kicked uh what's her
face off monique off i didn't give a
[ __ ] anymore
um
so she started watching that [ __ ] so
anyway i'm studying for my instrument
rating here for my uh
you know flying helicopters and stuff
and uh you know just looking up all this
stuff
you know on the internet blah blah blah
next thing i'm on amazon and i found a
documentary about the vietnam war called
the vietnam war miracle
and i'd watched like all of the i don't
know some war movies or something like
that so when i went on there it
suggested that it was only like 50
something minutes long so i was like all
right i'll check this [ __ ] out
and um
the i mean first of all it was an
incredible story but the stuff in there
about helicopters
um what those pilots did
and the fact that they were kids
and they were just talking about
you know it's a story about a bunch of
veterans
i guess reuniting coming back together
and and
you know having not seen each other for
so long and getting into this horrific
fire fight in the jungle and people
having like
being gravely injured and then they just
get whisked away in these helicopters
and they had no idea whether they lived
or not there's this amazing doctor in
there who had to be like 30 years old
doing like brain surgery
on these people and not knowing when
he's done with it is he ships them off
if they live or not and just everybody
coming together and realizing that they
saved people's lives
um
and just to distort just the the way the
documentary
makes you see like the bond that the
soldiers have and how they have each
other's backs and like the [ __ ] that's
going down and how they don't even
question running over to help
from something that every
you know nerve in your body would say
run in the other direction and they just
without question go over to help their
buddy out
and then you combine that with today
that now people like look at a tweet
they're like oh my god that was so brave
jessica i can't believe you're just such
a warrior it's like these people
are heroes they're unbelievable so
anyway the
helicopter part which of course you know
i loved
is
they had this fire fight right
and
you know vietcong comes in they're
sleeping and all of a sudden you see
this
and they just threw all these [ __ ]
grenades
like that's how they woke up right
um
the guys were sleeping out evidently
right and and
then they got to worry the whole rest of
the night if these if the vietcong is
coming back and they got to get these
guys out of here so they make a call for
the helicopters to come in
and i don't ruin the whole thing you got
to watch it vietnam wore a miracle right
but this is what killed me is landing a
helicopter off airport meaning not on a
pad or on a runway or a taxiway or
anything like that is one of the
scariest [ __ ] things you're gonna do
because it is so easy to roll the thing
over the second the ground is not level
and you're at an angle what you have to
do is you come down like it's
you're you're you're gonna land on
something level and you
the uphill skid touches first
and then you're balancing that skid
and then as you lower
your collective the emergency brake
looking thing to get that other one to
come down you turn the stick you push it
in the direction uphill so you don't tip
over and these guys were landing in the
jungle well god knows if there's even a
clearing you could hit a tree you're
[ __ ] dead and these guys would come
in and just land these things
while getting shot at
as these people screaming in pain and
agony are being thrown on now you're
getting weight thrown onto the
helicopter that is alive and is moving
and you're balancing that skid trying
not to tip over while getting shot at
and then flying out of there i mean it
was just insane
and um
this doctor
um who did the surgery on one of them
did the brain surgery on one of them who
then lived and then you know as i'm
sitting here bitching about
you know positive t-shirts
like the life that this guy led has led
um and how he
just embraced his new life when they
took 25 30 of his brain out it was
unreal
but
one of the cool things was because of
those guys who flew those helicopters
and how they were able to
get into a confined area and get injured
people out of there and save their lives
that is what what those kids did
showed the potential of helicopters and
that's why to this day
if you wipe out on a motorcycle or or
whatever get into a skiing exit or
something they bring a helicopter in it
gets you up and out and gets you fixed
it's because of those guys
and um i really wasn't thinking about it
but like you know helicopters
by the vietnam war had not been around
that long and certainly had not played a
significant role i believe in any sort
of warfare so
um i don't know it was a really really
uh
you know
i don't know it's one of those things if
you're kind of stressing about a
little [ __ ] like i have been lately it's
been a it's a really cool thing to watch
vietnam war miracle on uh amazon check
it out if you get a chance so with that
let me uh
let me read a little bit of advertising
by the way did i [ __ ]
i can't remember if i brought up that i
just had a [ __ ] steak and cheese out
here i can't [ __ ] remember
i don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
with my memory i just have to check in
to see if the red sox are winning here
this is completely unprofessional i
realize this
two to one losing the race we just can't
[ __ ] beat those guys god damn it
isn't that hilarious i just told you
guys if you want to see something not
stress about the little [ __ ] i'm gonna
flip out about a red sox score i'm an
idiot i'm an idiot you know but it pays
well all right helix everybody
you know sleeping can be difficult and
it shouldn't be
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preference to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep everyone's unique
and helix knows that you're all special
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot
i just love that sleeping hot
mattress great for spinal alignment
i could use that to prevent morning
aches and pains and even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers the big
boys
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and the mattress
comes right to your door ship for free
you don't even need to go to a mattress
store again just go to helixsleep.com
take the two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free gross
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it oh my god but you will
well for the people have to pick up the
mattress i hope you do love it uh helix
even has financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away helix is offering up
to 200 off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
that's helix l e oh sorry h e l i x
sleep.com
for up to 200
off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
um
all right oh roman everybody
you know most guys have tried different
ways to last longer but counting
backwards from 10 doesn't always work
roman swipes are clinically proven are a
clinically proven way to last longer in
bed they're effective easy to use and
fast acting but don't require a
prescription
roman can ship sweat
fast axing did you cut my dick off no no
he's just not both yeah there it is
sorry roman can ship swipes to you in
discreet unmarked packaging he's getting
his dick done you don't got to worry
about that and each swipe packet is
small enough to hide in your wallet for
whenever you need it
swipes are great uh swipes are great
that they will not transfer to your
partner so you can last longer without
worrying
dude you should put that thing on with
pride just tell her listen you're so
you're so good looking i can't last so
now i'm gonna do a little magic trick
i'm gonna put the little swipe you just
put it right over the helmet of your
dick you know what i mean like you're
doing a little three-card money
and now i take it away and magically
i'll be able to go long enough to
satisfy you
uh they're super easy to use just take
the swipes out of the packet swipe it
let it dry and you're good to go that's
it let it dry make sure you let it dry i
guess go to get roman.com
and get ten dollars off your first order
of swipes plus free two-day shipping
that's get roman g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n.com
for ten dollars off your first order of
swipes plus free two-day shipping
there you go
and with that um dude by the way you
know if you've outgrown your mattress at
what point are you going to go on a
[ __ ] diet
you know
i'm not trying to lose business for a
[ __ ] advertiser here but i think when
you you when you when you outgrow the
goddamn mattress that's the time you
know
to put on your walking shoes
right when a king size becomes a single
[Laughter]
you know
it's like me with my drinking back in
the day
when your wife who never gives you [ __ ]
says to you what's going on with you
when you're drinking and you're like
what nothing and she goes don't have any
more because when you drink a lot you
snore at night and the next thing you
know you're walking down the stairs
hiding another one on the outside of
your leg and you become that guy i
remember when i did that
and i was like i gotta stop doing this
[ __ ] and like you know took me like
another six months to stop so
you know if you're a big guy you know
and you [ __ ] got to buy a bigger
mattress you know give yourself six
months
at some point right
you got to be like all right
i need i need to start going for walks i
went for a [ __ ] walk today
look at all the happiness i got out of
it
i actually saw a guy on a bicycle you
know you know of course he's dressed
like lance armstrong you know because
nobody can just get on a [ __ ] bicycle
anymore and ride down the street you got
to be like all [ __ ] aerodynamic
me and my wife went into a target
and this lady in front of us i swear to
god just she had unlike these spandex
you know what i mean just like out
outlining her whole you know this lady i
don't know what she was like 50 60 years
old had on spandex it didn't have a long
shirt hanging over it and we're on an
escalator so her old
[ __ ] ass is just in front of us
and i got to be honest with you when i
was a kid you could not walk around i
don't think you'd walk around like that
wait a minute spandex came out in the
80s
i don't know there's something about
target in those big superstores where
just i think people there's just
something about it people don't think
about what they're wearing like
like they just don't give a [ __ ] because
i know walmart
gets a ton of [ __ ]
like there was
that website where people took pictures
of people going to a walmart you know
and that's what it became at let's make
fun of the people that go to the walmart
rather than let [ __ ] on the walmart for
putting everybody out of business so now
they have they don't have jobs so now
they dress like that and have to go to a
superstore
[Laughter]
so anyway we walk in there
and um
i am like such a [ __ ] dad and married
now that i actually really enjoy target
i got another thing too i use
self-checkout now i just don't give a
[ __ ] there's something about watching
people reject
masks and vaccines that i just quit now
it's like i'm not fighting any fight
anymore
i quit all right you win i'm broken i
don't give a [ __ ]
so my wife goes you're going to [ __ ]
you're going out to self-checkout you
never use self-checkout
and i was like i don't give a [ __ ]
anymore and i just walked over and i
just started going hi did you find
everything how was your experience today
at target did you find everything you
need i'm just scanning the dumb [ __ ]
then i go to stick my card in and it
just doesn't tell you the [ __ ] amount
it's like another 15 [ __ ] questions
you have to
answer and i started i just went like ah
i yelled at discreet and then my wife
you know finished the whole thing but um
yeah i've i've i let the flag hit the
ground
i know
i i now work as a cashier for free
at target
and other uh amazing superstores
i just i gave up i don't know what
happened i used to have the fight i just
don't have the fight anymore i just
don't give a [ __ ]
you know i'm rooting for the virus at
this point
i'm just gonna mask up
and uh you know
i'm just accepting that the rest of my
life when i go out i'm gonna have to put
a [ __ ] mask on
oh gives a [ __ ] um
anyway oh billy biceps
is [ __ ] building up the shoulders man
building up the shoulders i got uh
i got to keep up with my son
kid is already strong as hell
um
so
i'm doing the lat pull down machine my
my left shoulder is feeling good and
i'll tell you anybody else who has
shoulder problems i got one of those uh
you know those
you know those foam rollers that you
roll yourself
out on
that [ __ ] kill right i also have uh
you can't have like these little
exercise not exercise balls what would
you call them
little those little
ah
what do you call them they're like
[ __ ] these little hard balls that's
what she said right
they come in different sizes and in
different levels of of hardness
am i still doing the roman swipe
read right now anyway i got a little red
one no jesus the reference is here do
you bill you got a little red one is it
hard
um
yeah i [ __ ]
put it between the back my the wall in
my back
and i'm able to roll out my shoulder
after each workout and it hasn't been
talking to me
so uh like i said i got a little uh i
got this atlantic city gig
coming after the flight i'm
gonna bring that thing along hopefully
it doesn't get uh picked when i go
through the um
the security line because i was using
another one
a while back
uh for my legs
they're amazing to have i'll tell you
what what is underrated
um as you get older
uh stretching and getting a massage or
at least doing some sort of self-massage
thing and not those [ __ ] stupid guns
that everybody gets those things are
useless you got to get yourself a jedi
masseuse
all right and you got to keep going back
to the same person and then they know
what your problem is and then you get a
game plan
and then they try and work the [ __ ] out
if you combine that with working out and
stretching or whatever
you can you too can look as good
as i do i'm kidding
i look [ __ ] horrific
you know although i've been getting
along great with my wife lately do you
know what i did you know what i did
recently
and if you're a married guy you gotta do
this every once in a while you gotta you
gotta have the i had it
moment
i've had it with this [ __ ]
uh it's one of the few times a woman
will listen to a man in a relationship
is when they hear the magic words i've
had it
you know you can do your version i've
had it up to here cut it up to her you
can do whatever you want to do it
all right and the i've had it
i've found that like you know
you can't use it all the time if every
week you've had it they know that you
haven't had it
okay you just you gotta let [ __ ] build
up
and build up and build up and build up
and then then you then you that's when
you hit him with it
you know what when when
they get mad at you and you and you
stand your ground that you've had it
and they're mad and they're making the
face and and you still don't give a [ __ ]
then then they know
then they know they're like oh [ __ ]
he has [ __ ] had it
i know this sounds stupid but it
actually works
and me and my wife had a great
fight
and the the end result
is that we respect each other more and
we've been really nice to one another
and uh
and we like each other again
you know but the worst thing you can do
is not say anything
and then let the [ __ ] build up and then
flip the [ __ ] out
that doesn't work all right so i'm
telling you right now you gotta you
gotta you know
i think i just told versi that today on
our podcast
i think once every like 18 months you
can say it you can just be like you know
what i [ __ ] had it
sweat you're not talking to me
yeah i'm talking to you and i'm talking
to you and i'm letting you know i've had
it i've had it with this [ __ ] all right
enough
really really you're just going to ke i
don't i don't you know
have fun with that
have fun with that because in in all of
your [ __ ] you're going to shoot back at
me there's my point sitting in the
middle that is gonna be dealt with
you know why
you know why because i've had it
i've had it i'm gonna look that up i'm
gonna google that i've had it
let me see if that's a [ __ ] website
yet
i've had it
let's see
husband
i said husband and it actually went i've
had it with my husband
i've had it husband true story all right
let's see what this one is
we have your husband
one woman's it's always about the broads
we have your husband we have your
husband
true story my husband used to be a woman
wait did i need to put this in in quotes
is that what this person's
and do i gotta do each one in quote like
uh quote i've quote
to have a an effective google search
i've had it
you know what i'm going to do i'ma
[ __ ] look up videos see what the [ __ ]
this does
i've had it i've had it by the bell
notes
1959 youtube
bunch of husbands
i'll tell you i've had it with this song
[Music]
you guys haven't had it
well it just doesn't sound like you had
it this
[Music]
oh jesus christ
the bell notes
look how [ __ ] up my searches are man
freeze wolf from fence
next video it's not worth it bro
longest passing plays in nfl
history the most brutal
awd launches and accelerations i don't
know what that means
drums guitar guitar drums
i don't know
anyway so what do you guys think is it
going to be a one game yankee red sox
playoff
that's what i'm that's what i'm praying
for
because we're not going to win it this
year but we can beat any team anybody
can beat anybody one game
um
i mean obviously i think the yankees are
gonna win that they got they got a
better team this year but we got a
chance
i mean that's [ __ ] nuts as good as
the yankees they just won 13 games in a
row
then they'll play one game against the
stupid-ass red sox and we can actually
maybe knock them out of the [ __ ]
playoffs would be hilarious
um that's what i'm hoping for um anyways
sorry
i've had it by the bell notes 1959
i wonder if they had any more hits after
that
or were they just singing what the
record companies
said to them
all right gotta look them up i'll look
them up real quick and then they'll be
the bell notes
wiki oh they got a wikipedia page all
right good for them good for them they
made a little bit of money
bell notes wikipedia the bell notes were
an emer an early american rock and roll
group from east meadow area of long
island new york the bell notes were
regular performers in the bronx in the
1950s and performed at a bar owned by
their father
ray tabano are you [ __ ] doing
he and steven tyler of aerosmith
occasionally played between bell note
sets what
and covered the song i've had it
well it shows you what the [ __ ] i know
can you believe once again i was wrong
unbelievable it's almost like there's a
pattern
um all right that is it
go red sox win enough to have a one game
play up with the yankees and then me and
verzi can have a great bet i hope you
guys are having a great weekend um
that is all that's all i got enjoy the
music and then i got an extra bonus
episode of the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
coming up after this have a great
weekend you [ __ ]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
september 2nd oh happy labor day
everybody
huh why
doesn't work
um
is it labor day around the world
if it is happy labor day to all of you
guys out there especially ones that make
all of our clothes
huh everybody in the first world out
there come on let's have a nice round of
applause for the six-year-old in el
salvador who made your little cargo
pants
that you're walking around the cookout
with right now with your big stupid
pockets
your wife's rolling her [ __ ] eyes
going why does he keep wearing those
shorts he had in college
oh god the 90s are over why doesn't he
see it
why did i end up jumping on his dick
instead of that other guy's that other
guy he became a doctor and he wears
slacks now
um
for those of you around the world
listening to this podcast and my ego
tells me
that there is people around the world
you know maybe somebody sitting in a
bunker
right
listening to this [ __ ] over here in the
united states we have something called
labor day because we work so [ __ ]
hard
in this country
that's why we're number one
you know why because we outworked all of
you you bunch of lazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
actually we didn't
according to tom broke i was the
greatest generation they [ __ ] did
everything except raise their kids right
you know
they raised their kids right where they
reacted to the vietnam war the way they
did now they would have gone to the
pacific the same way they did in world
war ii we got a job to do it's got to
get done no one wants to do it [ __ ] it
i'm volunteering
right
they were so shell-shocked from that
they couldn't even look at their kids
and then their kids just grew up all
spoiled rotten
and then all of a sudden it was their
turn to go and then they were just like
hey man like don't harsh to mellow man
right and that was the beginning of the
end
i'm telling you right now
if less people dodged the vietnam war
you wouldn't have as many fat people in
this [ __ ] country right now okay if
you can't do the math on that one then
you know what i can't help you
that's one of my new things
is i just make stupid statements to
people in bars right that connect
in no way possible and as i watch their
forehead wrinkle up
i throw in and if you can't do the math
then i can't help you
it's a [ __ ] wonderful game because
it's so it it puts somebody remember
when you were like in like junior high
grade school junior high or whatever and
kids first started talking about sex and
they would be like do you know what this
is and you had no idea but you didn't
want to admit to it
you know because you didn't want to be
the kid who didn't know even though
nobody was [ __ ] anything at that
point right but you just didn't want to
be the dummy that's what i'm tapping
into
all right if you can't do the math on
that then i can't help you i'm telling
you guys and when you say i can't help
you you got to look away
and just let them sit with that
you know i'm just sitting with him but
that didn't make any sense well
should i let it go is anybody else
noticing that i i don't know what it
means
um anyways labor day i i don't know what
the history of it is
i'm sure i could look it up on wikipedia
but so could you
you know
what am i your [ __ ] reader
do you want me to do it because i will
i'll look it up right now
i'll [ __ ] click on this right here
right
and then i'm going to type in labor day
l-a-b-e-r
it's b-o-r jesus christ
labor day history
what is the history of labor day you
know there's gonna be something horrific
labor day
politics history begins with workers
strikes in 1890s you knew it you knew
there was going to be some sort of
bloodshed
right and then we all forget years later
we're just sitting around a [ __ ] big
green egg smoking a big pork shoulder
which is what i'm doing right now uh
rose bowl legend
uh jason lawhead will be joining the uh
um
i should really clarify that rose bowl
tailgate legend
i keep calling us legends like we're
actually out there playing the game
oh look at that an advertisement for
hertz rental car you know what i think
i'm actually going to switch to them
this is free advertising for those [ __ ]
because whenever i go to the airport and
i'm waiting for [ __ ] budget those
douche bags i think they have one bus at
every airport
and i've really tried to sit there and
be like okay am i just impatient
and so i just started counting buses and
i got to tell you hertz and avis they
got a lot of buses national and alamo
they're kind of like uh i don't know
they're from the other side of the
tracks you know they didn't come for
money but they're working their way up
they got to share a bus
you know but it's building character
over there there's a lot of character
over at alamo and uh national but i'll
tell you budget
budget uh budget wasn't raised right you
need to stay away from them
i've had it with those [ __ ]
i've had it with them i've been with
them for [ __ ] ever i've had it with
them all right labor day's political
history begins with worker strikes in 18
in the 1890s yeah this is when we had
sweatshop labor over here which is why
we created unions
so that they would stop and then the
unions literally became the [ __ ]
thing that they were fighting
right leaning on shovels some on break
and all that [ __ ] thing taking
advantage of it and then the corporate
[ __ ] said oh yeah
well you know good luck to you and your
union we're taking the factory to
another country
go on strike all you want we're still
making money
all right there you go
like the marginal line they flew right
over the [ __ ]
so now here we are all right and that
poor guy and rage against the machines
got to bring his ukulele all over the
[ __ ] country to try and get the
people of this nation refocus on what
the purpose of a union is
huh because all those hey man people
they all had kids
all right and then they joined unions
and then everything left all right and
if you can't do the [ __ ] math on that
then i can't help you feel that i just
walked away i can't help
um
labor day has fallen upon us once again
oh this guy what a writer
has it really fallen upon us has it
graced itself
uh with its with our graced ourselves
with its presence is that how we say it
labor day has fallen upon us once again
i would love to look up the douchebag
who wrote this and find out how many
[ __ ] articles he started that way
you know just the way there's this this
hacky stand-up comics there's also hacky
writers like i refuse
do you bill are you really refusing can
you feel the world shaking in its
[ __ ] boots
um
[ __ ] you i have my my my
i have my standards that i live by i
like to think
piece of [ __ ] standards but standards
nonetheless
um i don't i refuse to read any
celebrity
interview that begins with what they're
eating
i think that's the hackiest way
just i i've met a zillion john travolta
you know breaks into some [ __ ] medium
rare steak wearing a smart button down
shut the [ __ ] up and just ask him what
it was like to be a dance fever
all right
just say hey i'm a star [ __ ] and i
can't believe i get to sit across from
this icon
it's amazing that when he eats he also
gets [ __ ] on his face you wouldn't think
that from an oscar winner
um all right for most americans we're
back to the article now this means
little more than the end of the summer
oh really you're going to talk down to
me right at the beginning of the [ __ ]
article
joseph
for your [ __ ] horn rim glasses from
the 80s all right for most americans
this means a little more than the end of
the summer social season oh well you
know he's actually right because i i did
have to look this thing up kids and
college students alike returned to
school leaving relieved parents to grasp
some sense of normalcy
yeah jesus could be more [ __ ]
dramatic
uh cookouts flare on and friends get
together for cool drinks after some
outdoor fun was this written in the 20s
uh
no because there hasn't been anything
racist yet
we're playing horseshoes back then they
probably used like a black guy they just
hammered his head into the ground and
used him as like a steak and nobody said
anything wrong with it
right
isn't that how bad the racism was back
then i might be wrong on that one i
don't know all right amid all the action
everyone seems to forget that labor day
what labor day is all about well for the
love of god joseph can you get to the
[ __ ] point we get it you know what it
is and we don't
ah what an [ __ ] you know what in his
picture he has his glasses on but as i
read this i picture him taking them off
right now
to give me a little talking to
um during the late 1800s labor leaders
labor
uh decided that hard-working americans
deserved a holiday of their own
in other words they felt them getting
ready to storm the castle this is the
old bread and circus
after 1894's
monumental pullman railroad strike
congress decided to federalize this
holiday
ah god
and let me guess
the [ __ ] morons agreed to it hey we
wanted equal pay and we wanted some
decent hours hey how about we give you
one day off a year
is it gonna be beer
of course it's gonna be beer oh you can
drink oh i don't know about that fella
sounds pretty good to me plays a jolly
good fellow and that's the end of it
they completely lose their focus
um
the pullman strike had such a
wide-ranging implication
that less than a week after it ended the
president
that then ah [ __ ] president grover
cleveland signed the labor day act into
law now if you can't [ __ ] do the math
on them
don't you see what's happening this
strike happened and all the [ __ ] blue
blood douchebags with their top hats
chomping on a cigar
walking around like the [ __ ] penguin
they saw what was coming
people were like we've had it
we're not gonna take this anymore and
we're coming for you you tuxedo [ __ ] on
a tuesday how much money do you have
that you're wearing that get up on a
[ __ ] tuesday right back then
they had spats
right
showed up a big long car
they didn't try to hide it
so
they saw what the [ __ ] was coming
and then you know grover cleveland so
who's kidding who how did he get in
office all those rich [ __ ] right so
they get him hey grover
um you're supposed to call me mr
president grover
get in here
waddle your fat ass in here you [ __ ]
listen
okay
if this [ __ ] what happened at the
pullman strike happens straight across
this land we're not gonna have the money
to keep the [ __ ] coming in to suck
your dick while your wife's in the other
room do you want that to happen
it was a rhetorical question just listen
to us okay we need to have a [ __ ] day
off for these people just give them one
[ __ ] day off we'll smoke a pork
shoulder we'll get them a bunch of beer
they'll be so fat and [ __ ] hung over
they'll be good till christmas
all right just do this for us so we can
keep all the money can you do that for
us
haven't we done enough for you your
[ __ ] name is grover cleveland and we
still got you the oval office all right
we ready on two on two ready break
um all right sorry
i think i don't need to read the rest of
this isn't that what happened
considering then both u.s soldiers and
federal law enforcement officers killed
a number of strikers
this was the least that he could do
oh yeah
god forbid you protest that you're
working [ __ ] 900 hours a goddamn week
you know
not jesus christ see this is before they
had like [ __ ]
you know cnn and fox news to spin it and
all that type of crap
all he had was word of mouth going
around
you know
i'm sure they had newspapers they have
newspaper people read back in the 1800s
all right i know i'm just sounding
dumber by the second but i think i made
some sort of point there i'd like to
think i did
uh well let's let's this is actually
fascinating to me enough
let's read some more about jason's
article
said his name joseph sorry
uh minimum wage laws were a long way off
and if one thinks the health insurance
is bad now it was non-existent then then
there is
the gilded ages near total lack of
workplace sanitation and fair pace pay
standards oh yeah like when they built
like the brooklyn bridge like they
averaged like five guys dying a day a
day something crazy because they didn't
understand the bends and as they were
bringing somebody up and they'd start to
get it they're like bring him up quicker
he's getting sick and then that would be
it
um that was it your dad went to work and
he died
you know there was no 60 minutes
you know coming out to [ __ ] help you
ed bradley or some [ __ ]
is he still around he died too a lot of
people died on that show
um well it's been around for 50 years
bill a lot of people died on the brady
bunch at this point no
alice is still alive
i don't know about sam the butcher
mike died
the dad died dad always dies
you know [ __ ] working his ass off
um
trying to drop some plans and [ __ ]
florence henderson coming in with the
world's first mullet
you know
uh where the [ __ ] am i thankfully scores
of long-pressed laborers eventually got
together and formed unions as
individuals they were all but powerless
to bring about the positive change in
large groups though they managed to
secure the american dream not only for
themselves but for generations to come
throughout the 20th century democrats
typically favor the interest of
non-managed workers while republicans
cater to administrators and business
owners why do you got to throw the
hatfields mccoys in there
you know it's us
versus the five percent of them
okay stop with the yankee red sox [ __ ]
god damn it radicals in both parties
often destroyed the chance for
reasonable solutions to com okay that's
fair to complex financial problems but
moderate voices often prevailed
that should explain our country's
economic
success for most of the 1900s well i
imagine there's more to it than that but
what the [ __ ]
so there you go people there's a little
ignorant history on this wonderful
[ __ ] day and here we are
120 years later and uh i'm sitting
around today doing a podcast
smoking a pork shoulder i made a [ __ ]
apple pie
oh it's going down calories calories
will be consumed
on this wonderful day um
you know what would be great is if
somehow
you could just eliminate greed
envy jealousy paranoia lost basically
the seven deadly sins
okay
look i'm far from a [ __ ] perfect
person oh geez
uh but it would be good just at least at
that [ __ ] level
you know fabric you'd be like hey you
know i'm making enough money yeah why we
should you know
give you health insurance
i love that whole [ __ ] myth that if
you actually treat workers decently like
a [ __ ] t-shirt is gonna cost fifty
dollars
it isn't
in order for you to continue maintaining
your [ __ ] giant yacht it would cost
that when i was a kid you know
factories were just starting to go
overseas but they made a lot of [ __ ]
here and sneakers weren't the equivalent
of [ __ ] 200 or whatever the [ __ ] they
said that they were gonna be it's all
[ __ ] i don't buy a [ __ ] word of
it
and uh that's it all right i'm not gonna
talk anymore because at this point i'm
probably even sounding more ignorant
than usual but uh my gut tells me i'm
right
so go [ __ ] yourselves whoo i just bailed
out of that one didn't i
nice barrel roll right out of a [ __ ]
moving car
um so most of you are probably asking
not most of you but a lot of you or
maybe none of you
but none of you can call in to tell me
you're not thinking this so i'm gonna go
with this and say you are thinking this
[ __ ] you're probably wondering what
exactly is a pork shoulder you're eating
the shoulder of a pork it's actually the
pig's ass
but you would sell a lot less of them i
think if you said you know
you know pig ass pig rectum some people
go pig butt that's the closest they'll
say
but uh yeah we're eating the uh the ass
of a pig
we're smoking the [ __ ]
and uh
it's gonna be delish
um so anyways let's get on with the
podcast here everybody did you watch any
uh any of the college football this
weekend
lawhead come on in oh look
here huh jump on wait wait wait i gotta
i'll tell who's
give you a proper intro this you've
never been on the podcast right
ladies and gentlemen we have here the
living legend he's tipping the cap
i i keep saying rose bowl legend it's
gotta be uh rose bowl uh uh tailgate
legend tailgate legend hall of fame grab
the microphone right there grab the mic
a touchdown in a rose bowl
but we're built we've built a program
here
because when we started this thing it
was ugly it was bad i mean we were like
33 no you weren't even probation you you
weren't even there the first tailgate
the first two years you showed up to the
second one but you weren't cooking you
were at another one right exactly the
first year
i i think i remember was being drunk
and
bartnik
putting butter on the steaks with two
fingers with his index finger with his
middle finger because we didn't have any
utensils doing that today and i had this
little hibachi
and uh i just remember i didn't know how
to cook i didn't know how to grill or
anything like that i kept flipping the
steak and i heard this guy go please
please stop flipping that steak
[Music]
hopefully it was an ohio state fan or no
that was the second year i showed up
this was the first the first year
this is already how long we've been
doing this and how i'm starting to feel
like the old man over there the first
year we went there it was usc versus
penn state [ __ ] mark sanchez sanchez
was quarterback for usc
pete carroll was still coach wow joe
paterno
joe paterno had never been uncovered yet
and well i mean well you know yeah but
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] uh i actually did
stand up for both teams down at the
improv they had like this pre thing so
one night they had us one day they had
usc one day
they had penn state joe paterno was not
there i often wondered was sandusky
there i mean granted everybody there he
was off the staff
if they got to another rose bowl after
what all that has happened you might
down a little bit sorry do you think
that they would ever penn state would
ever go to an improv comedy show like
that now
even you know just yeah i think they're
risky
some guy that might i think they would
because they're already on tv
and yesterday i caught myself going oh
let's see how they rebuild this and then
i had to think wait rebuild it from the
pedophile case but they're already like
they're bringing joe paterno's statue
back out and uh you know they took it
down like he was [ __ ] saddam hussein
but i mean dude
i i don't want to get into that whole
subject because i love the guy but i
just don't know
no matter what generation no matter how
old you are
how
you like you know what it is dude it's
power it's money it's the reputation
there was so much [ __ ] on the line that
they tried to [ __ ] how to handle it i
don't know yeah
who knows let's not even talk about that
we got to put our shoulder right now
stop smoking
so they uh so that first year
um
i didn't think we had cigars we might
add cigars but dude we got absolutely
[ __ ] annihilated i think all we had
was the steaks or maybe burgers i can't
i can't [ __ ] remember all i remember
dude i was so cause you gotta understand
when you guys go there like you you help
with the drinking with bartnik i was
going like one on one
like if bartnik was a wrestler we'd have
to all come running in from the locker
room to try to take him down but i was
sitting there mud wrestling seeing some
stripes when everybody all the girls had
to go take down giant yeah beat the [ __ ]
out of a mosque
um i actually saw that actor who played
uh he played psycho francis sawyer yeah
i saw him in an episode of tj hooker t.j
hooker some of the worst acting ever
ever yeah and he's still great
he's still great in it he's just he just
was a [ __ ]
great mammoth is that what his name was
no no the other guy his partner hooker's
partner the good looking guy the young
guy who played an italian but he was
adorable he was uh
armenian armenian
eastern bloc and he played he played uh
romano was his name i mean his last name
started with a z he wasn't italian yeah
his real last name was like a z-y-m-t
and then it was like a
well you have to watch it because they
they never call him tj
they just call him hooker the whole time
so that they'll be like when tj's in a
difficult situation they'll be trying to
find him out and and they've got the
walkie-talkie going hooker
hooker and it's just like that i heard
hooker from the day i was born so like
why
how the [ __ ] did they that get on the
air like why wouldn't you just pick
something else
that's probably why they just threw the
tj in the title so they could just have
the tj but knew that they were yeah but
they never used it
i don't think you're gonna get away with
like hooker friday night hooker on cbs
everybody although that was everywhere
but i'm saying the characters could have
said [ __ ] uh
could have said like tj right
tj dj that's still bad that is bad call
him tommy tommy hooker tom thomas
he needs more of a man he built this
program to what it is today i mean this
is like now it's
from where it started to now we're
smoking
meats oh the day starts with the omelet
starts with the heater who's
starts off with a whiskey then you have
a [ __ ] 100 of these joe bartnik i
could drink a hundred of these i love
when he does that
literally joe barnick after his first
sip of whiskey when it hits his lips he
looks around everybody in this like
strong whispery voice i could drink a
hundred of these and then the night's
the the day's on and he loses his ticket
and then waits for us at the the game oh
i don't even know if i even brought that
up from last year that was the worst
[ __ ] that was like the willem dafoe
moment and platoon left him behind
somehow
he he lost his ticket he got picked so
big he put him in his back pocket and i
think because i walked to the stadium
with him you guys were a little ahead of
us because he was moving slow you know
joe's a big dude he had about
100 of these in him right and uh so i
was kind of like staying his pace like
helping him and then we get to the gate
and he goes right to his back pocket and
it's gone and i'm like i looked about
i'm like ah we walked around but it was
one of those things like if somebody had
their game on and they saw that thing
sticking out of his back pocket if he's
just you could just i mean those crowds
you swipe it and you're gone or if it
just fell on the ground pick it up you
just go scalp it or something
yeah so he had he had to stay outside
that was the [ __ ] worst uh hey is it
true that they don't sell booze at the
road no booze at the rose bowl that's we
we're so in the i never know these by
then that we don't even five years and i
never noticed yeah they don't so bad i
got to do i got to do a couple
advertising right here if you're just
tuning in i'd like to say that like this
is actual radio station rather than
people downloaded it uh we're talking
three to two in the tent rose bowl
tailgate legend uh jason lawhead he's
over here smoking a [ __ ] pig's ass
uh all right uh dollar shave club
everybody there are so many things in
this world that irritate me uh people
with neck pillows
people ride bicycles and don't get over
and feel like i have to drive as slow as
them because they want to go out on a
ride uh my own cowardice
that annoys me uh when so many things
can irritate you why add razors to that
list it's time to stop milking your
razor blade everybody i know what the
brand name razors are used to paying
outrageous prices and exhausting those
razors until they start to look like a
rusty soda can well listen it's time to
move on god damn it dollar shave club
delivers amazing quality blades to your
door just for a few bucks a month never
think about it again they send a pack uh
every month why don't they ever have
month
in the damn copy he says they send the
send a pack every so you can change your
blades every week
um they send
a pack every month all right uh i love
these guys and your face will love them
too they also have a new product called
one wipe charlie's jay i swear to god i
refuse to believe this is real it's a
butt wipe for men come on and it's
classy
it's classy how how can wait wait wait
wait wait it goes check out the video
for that
and sign up for your razors today
what
this is like
you know you know what it is it's like
the columbia house of razors this
company is like
no they're great dude this is like this
is like the poor man's bidet
you know you can't afford the spray of
water but it's classy it's classy which
means it's a nice thickness so when you
wipe it it's not going to tear and make
your fingers all shitty over there uh go
to
dollarshaveclub.comforwardslash burr
dollarshaveclub.com or go to
com that's
billboard.com and click on the dollar
shave club banner hey the lady and your
life's gonna love you you're gonna have
a nice clean shave and uh you're gonna
have a clean bottom you friggin animal
all right
hulu plus
i'm sure you've tried hulu.com if you
haven't you're a loser and i want you to
know that came from my heart but i want
to tell you about hulu plus hulu plus
lets you watch thousands of hit shows
anytime anywhere stream it on your tv or
go with your smartphone or tablet um why
stand in line or
ride a train and just stare at your feet
you could be watching your favorite
shows on hulu plus or hitting on the hot
chick standing next to you but whatever
floats your boat hula plus is a great
way to binge watch your favorite shows
hulu plus has tons of episodes from
great comedies like snl community modern
family south park family guy and
thousands of other shows hulu plus is
only 7.99 a month you cheap bastards
7.99 for all for all the shows and
movies you can watch catch up on current
shows uh binge on old favorite
favorites or catch a great movie you can
do it all on hulu plus right now you can
try hulu plus for a couple of weeks free
on me when you go to the podcast page
billbird.com and click on the hulu plus
banner or go to huluplus.com bill that's
as easy as it can get me please make
sure you use huluplus.com so you can get
an extended free trial and so they know
that we sent you all right makes me a
little bit of keshish and it makes your
viewing pleasures
go through the roof i guess is that what
i'm trying to say all right and we're
back to the podcast here everybody
uh you're like you turned into like the
paul harvey of podcasters now you're
playing like live spots like right now
you know like paul harvey no that was
actually or you know charming tissue
paper
charming tissue and then you'd go right
and now the rest of the story charming
tissue wrap a [ __ ] in it and light them
on fire it's 1945.
um
yeah back then when they would do like
the promos for the war i was watching
all this ever since i've been reading
these world war ii
uh
books and stuff and just watching some
of those
those like
uh
propaganda films that they have like
dude like the the um
the work they would actually show like
literally like war crimes like strafing
i guess was considered a war crime which
is basically if you had people like
defenseless in the water after you shot
down their ship or whatever shot down
the ship torpedoed their ship they would
just see the survivors in the war and
they'd come
[Music]
and they would show that they do it to
us it was brutal it was war man it's
[ __ ] brutal but what kills me is you
think they try to keep it quiet but they
were describing one
showing strafing in in a movie theater
the crowd was going nuts and he goes
there they are boys let him have it and
then he goes they deserve it
it's like phil it's like a phil hartman
sketch
you know
and they got to like the
they always had the music behind it too
like
like the happy like parade music
no i was at the risk of repeating myself
from last week like both sides
viewed each other like they were animals
like they thought that we we bled green
blood and we had tails
and uh i don't know we we said we both
said they each side was it was devils
they said you know if the americans come
kill yourself because they're going to
eat you and all this type of stuff and
they were actually
uh committing acts of cannibalism
dude i've read that this book fly boys
i'm telling you there's a chapter in
there
like i had to set it down and walk away
for a little bit and then plow my
because it was such a good book just
that one chapter on that dude it was uh
i don't know what to do we're smoking a
pork shoulder i don't need to be talking
about this smoking pork shoulder we're
going to be making some coleslaw bro
coleslaw yeah but i don't need to be
talking about [ __ ] cannibalism if you
had to if you had to eat a person
all right jay i got to ask you this
um what's the body type you would be
looking for you wouldn't want survival
or enjoyment
uh like if i had to like string it out
over like if i had to like stock my
shelf well or if i just really wanted a
nice put on a nice suit and and i don't
want you to go hannibal i want you to be
let's consider for a second that i'm
surprised at that that reaction but
let's just say you're you know what i
mean like is it one night out or is it
on an island
john goodman if i'm you know what i mean
like yeah but okay john goodman will be
nice and marbled yeah there'll be a lot
of flavor in there
you got an athlete it's gonna be too
tough exactly you know right that's why
that's why i ask and then you got to get
that you know what you're the best one
you got you got to get that married guy
who used to work out but now he's got
four kids i figured that would be
travolta that would be the best eats
he's like the nice nice middle of the
road kind of a guy
yeah and he used to dance yeah he's like
still sleeping in areas where you could
taste really good
like his no you think like like now it's
like his nose or his double chin would
taste really good like i'd be like a
snack no that's too exotic
i i i ate it that's like the pig
no pig cheek i ate it one time and i
started like sweating after my body was
just like what kind of [ __ ] meat is
this no you gotta you gotta go with the
nightmares for like a month straight
yeah you gotta go with travolta's pork
shoulder yeah all right let's uh okay
let's go with this uh philip seymour
hoffman
or uh
or john travolta
john travolta be more like an age stake
this
you have to do a lot of cleaning like
you'd have to cut
like
this chocolate looks like he waxes so
you wouldn't have to go off that you
wouldn't have to like you know
chop so much of the hair off
you know if i could kill a bear
you have to really work the bear over
all i'm thinking right now is louis de
palma let's get out of this hey you're a
big college football fan what'd you
watch this weekend well obviously i was
in vegas this weekend i watched my
buckeyes we didn't look great but uh got
some work to do on defense number two in
the country
oh yeah wait we might be seeing them uh
that you know you guys you guys can't
pull got yourself out of the hole real
quick like that guy in the viagra
commercial when he hooks the truck up to
the horse right well we got herb man
urban meyer that guy goes everywhere
that guy goes he wins i mean his winning
percentage is ridiculous it's like 870.
i mean he's he can't have undefeated
season at utah one i'm not as deep as
you now he's not the guy who was there
when they got suspended he left right
right dress was gone the white haired
guy oh that's gone we had the defensive
coordinator was like i remember him for
one year uh thank god meyer got sick of
his family after a couple of years oh i
would spend time with my family now
luckily they were annoying and he's back
on the scene you know what i mean and uh
yeah you guys got two national titles he
probably could have won one
um in utah if it was before it was prop
uh prior bcs you know alex smith he
recruited alex smith uh you know why did
i hear like they're getting rid of the
bcs like this is the last year they're
gonna go to the they're gonna go to that
final four type thing they're gonna go
to uh finally like uh somewhat of a
playoffs oh you gotta play two game oh
yeah you're gonna basically have a final
for an ncaa football final four do you
know how huge that's going to be
ridiculous and you know most of the
games will be played right here in our
backyard right here i mean they're if
they there'd be idiots not to use
pasadena for that
that's going to be amazing i got to tell
you i watched my lsu tigers
playing the uh tcu
you go frogs oh frogs
hey you know what's funny is i i
couldn't find the [ __ ] game because i
kept looking up lsu and it was and all i
saw was versus texas christian
university and i'm so dumb
i didn't i didn't know what they all
they never said it the whole game they
didn't go come on texas christian
university they went tcu
frogs come on frogs that was the game we
saw them against wisconsin that was the
game when we basically knew then we had
to up our game in the tailgate realm it
was that tcu wisconsin game like was
that two yeah and that guy next to us
had the flat screen team yeah that's
when we were like dude what are we doing
we thought we had we thought we came
more prepared from the year before which
was right and then we were like last
year last year the first time we had
people walk looking at our tailgate
going see those guys they're doing it
right people are coming over every time
i lift them up another big one is women
when women start looking over going
because women don't forget anything no
yeah we had like moms like wisconsin
moms coming over going what are you
cooking like
what is that people were like kind of
like trying to be nice to us to see if
we'd offer them some when it was done
like get them that guy oh yeah it was
great
he's the greatest singer but uh i
watched the uh the ls lsu tcu game and i
i got to tell you about this is supposed
to be a rebuilding year for us this is
my team
but i got to tell you uh boston
well dude what am i what am i gonna be
you got that football program they're
gone yeah and uh bc i i never was a i
liked their hockey but i just was never
into the football team i just was never
into it yeah i never liked the uniforms
well yeah i just did that maroon with
the gold i just never they're good
everyone like once every 10
they years every
amazing job we had some great coaches
there the [ __ ]
guy there with the the
the rosacea on his face from the wind
burn oh tom coughlin yeah we had him
when it's not in season i can't remember
anybody's [ __ ] name but anyways we
got that mettenberger guy at quarterback
and now they're not switching off he
actually looks really [ __ ] solid they
got cam cameron now in his the uh qb
coach dude everywhere phillip rivers
drew brees and uh what's his face joe
flacco won the super bowl last year he
coached all of those guys so i feel good
about that they got they got this new
kid ego ferguson it's great isn't it sec
[ __ ] great name anthony johnson both
those guys were beasts yesterday
um and then they're saying that you know
the receivers are right odell beckham's
all right that's going to be a good year
in the sec because i i mean obviously
well that's what we're doing here we're
doing spurrier ball if lsu didn't have
that one that one fumble that blue kid i
don't know whose fault it was but
dropped it right there and just
basically gave him seven points
uh but tcu actually looks strange
and their [ __ ] uniforms are great
yeah it was black i'm like did you hear
what blue why they had that uh no it's
purple well purple black on purple yeah
yeah but why they had the uh that red
stripe no
because i guess when the horn toad or
whatever the [ __ ] it is the horn frog
when it gets mad and it gets upset blood
comes out of its eyes
yeah so that's what that's supposed to
be we gotta see one i gotta see one of
those in real life i've never seen one
in real life like are they zoos or do
they exist they do well how you do the
sign that they have is it's it's the
fred samford
i got the arthritis hands
i can't work i can't pick it
up hey do you need to check on yeah let
me check on that shoulder all right man
yeah and then come back so anyways yeah
so i am uh
i am now referring to lsu as is my team
as uh
just because i don't know i just did
that acting gig down there and i got to
tell you i actually missed new orleans
new orleans however the [ __ ] you say it
i
i was there long enough to see the
regular people where they live and those
[ __ ] awesome houses i got to tell you
the humidity
is for the [ __ ] birds
um
but
i don't know
i i really liked it and i actually was
getting into the saints it was just a
fun town party town people like to booze
i like taboos people like sports i like
sports
you know the only thing was missing was
a [ __ ] hockey team and then i liked
the fact that they named that team the
pelicans and everyone was giving them
[ __ ] including me and they were starting
to [ __ ] bond over the fact that
nobody liked their name
and uh i don't know i spent too much
time down there and i fell in love with
the [ __ ] city go ahead sue me
so
when lawheads comes back we're gonna
talk about our upcoming trip out to
denver um
what am i going to talk about now is it
time to get into the questions oh [ __ ]
37 minutes in let's get into the
questions for this week everybody
uh syria general billy patton here's
what's going on in syria i love that he
starts with that other in other words i
kind of [ __ ] up
what uh whatever i said was going on
last week so here's the real deal i
guess assad is killing his people now
that's the uh
the grand poobah
who's in charge over there he's killing
his people not all of his people just
the people that don't like him and
anybody who's standing near him i think
anyways equally terrible rebels
some of whom are al qaeda are now going
to be supported by the us military
now you're probably wondering well why
do we support anything that al qaeda is
doing because there it's it's a money
thing i guess this assad isn't doing
what we want them to do so uh we're
going to try and support the [ __ ] uh
the marlins right
did that work did the marlins suck this
year i have no idea anyway estimated up
to 1.5 million civilians have been
displaced that means homeless i guess so
now we're going to bomb syria
but also target some of russia's [ __ ] in
syria yeah because they're supporting
uh the assad guy what's my call
well i gotta tell you
russia is the six and nine team that
nobody wants to play
i mean what the [ __ ] do i know
i don't know what's going on over there
i don't know who's i look
i know that the only reason why we're
over there is because of [ __ ] money
and something that comes out of the
ground other than that we don't give a
[ __ ]
all right we don't we didn't give a [ __ ]
about the people in new orleans why
would we give a [ __ ] about them over
there it's all about [ __ ] i don't i
don't know and whether that is the
proper way to do it or if that's an evil
way of doing
what's goes on around the world i have
no idea
because i've never sat in in a meeting
in the pentagon so i have no idea what's
going to go on over there i feel bad for
all the innocent people
sitting there in the crossfire and i
feel lucky that i can lay in a bed and
do a podcast right now we need some
[ __ ] poor pig's ass that's all i got
for you sir what's my call um
well it's an uphill battle i'd have to
say i mean it's a home game for assad
and uh now that they brought in the
russians i mean well they don't have the
greatest record they well they beat the
[ __ ] germans
that was great
they just backed into their own country
and just burned and blew up dams and
bridges and all that [ __ ] they [ __ ]
raped their own goddamn country so
the russians would have nothing to [ __ ]
they drew them in and then the winner
came and then that was it they did the
old rope-a-dope before [ __ ] ali
so you got to give them that one
then but then they lost in afghanistan
that's always a hard thing though
when you when you got a road game
in the game of war that's such a [ __ ]
hard one to win
because uh
the occupying game because they know
eventually you're going to [ __ ] leave
right eventually
you know your soldiers are going to want
to go home
right sit down have a [ __ ] sandwich
and get any i don't know
find love and get on with their [ __ ]
life
so that's i don't know
afghanistan that's a tough one man
you know what they are they like the
charges in the first round of the
playoffs just a very very dangerous team
um
so what's my call i think it's going to
cost
billions of dollars it's going to make a
couple people uh a billion dollars and
everybody else is just going to be
suffering that's what i think is going
to happen and it's probably going to
ruin some of the environment that's what
that's my call uh more of the same sir
and it's just going to breed more hatred
and it's not going to solve anything
that's what i think
all right onward and upward towards new
levels
of misery all right grass-fed steak
uh dear bill bunches
you talked about juicing and all that
have you switched to grass-fed steak
switch to it i've been eating it the
whole [ __ ] time i do two juices a day
and then i throw down for dinner
right
i eat like a yoga instructor for the
first two [ __ ] meals and then i eat
like john wayne
so well it's better than doing it three
times a day
um
anyways he said it's amazing it tastes
like steak tasted like 15 20 years ago
before they started pumping the cows
full of everything well i think they've
been doing it longer than that haven't
they there's a company called grass-fed
beef company that rogan talked about and
had the owner on his podcast i highly
recommend
uh i'll cool i highly recommend the joe
rogan experience podcast because it's
the exact opposite of this one where i
just say [ __ ] with no facts behind it
borderline makeup stuff
um he actually uh
oh [ __ ] he got a tv show on about joe
rogan questions everything
so um
this is like i i do what i do on this
podcast is kind of like you know when
you had what you thought was a cool
teacher and then years later you
realized he was completely irresponsible
and wasn't doing his job
slash maybe trying to [ __ ] one of the
students that's what i do here
what rogan does rogan actually teaches
the class he earns his paycheck all
right there you go probably just lost
some [ __ ] listeners but you know what
every once in a while even i have to
tell the truth you know
uh
back to school mr burr do you miss going
back to school
i miss the social aspects of it i miss
if i could have appreciated
going
like going back to school especially if
you're in like a public school that's
like going to a club with no cover
charge
and every woman is in there is single
and is in their prime
you know as are you
all the guys have full heads of hair
right
all the ladies yeah they're looking good
i mean just to [ __ ] shooting fish in
a barrel
you don't need no opening lines or
anything what's your sign but you know
you've been going to school for [ __ ]
ever
you got to do hey you know just shoot
the [ __ ] with them i wish i knew that
i did not know that
hence i was a complete failure failure
in that department anyways because i'm
31 and every year around this time i
think about how fun it was to go back to
school despite the fact that i hated
summer ending and didn't want to be in
class you knew you didn't have a choice
and focused on the good things like
which girls are going to come back hot
will there be a new hot girl in school
i'm glad i get to see the girl i had a
crush on last year but didn't see all
summer because i was a nerd and had no
balls what do you miss
yeah i miss all of that
i miss running into my friends because
back before you even had a car like you
wouldn't see even most of your friends
all summer
um
yeah i missed out on a lot of [ __ ]
that's like when star wars came out
and we didn't have uh
you know we only had three channels
and we didn't have the ones that the
kids watched the uhf stations and i
guess that that's where they advertised
it i don't know we were living in a
bubble i went outside every day played
in the woods played sports went swimming
i completely missed out when star wars
came out
and uh when i got back to school in
september everybody was talking about it
and i had no idea what anybody was
talking about i just had to kind of like
uh
just stand there and then people
realized that i wasn't contributing
you know i felt like steve carell in
[ __ ] 40 year old virgin when he's
talking about feeling up a girl saying
it feels yeah like a bag of
sand
you know when he said that like that's
what i i had nothing
and um
so finally somebody asked me they're
like you know
bill did you see star wars and i was
like uh no
actually i didn't and then all the
little kids oh my god you didn't see and
let it [ __ ] lose it no that was it
and i got trashed i literally got
trashed for the rest of
recess
what's wrong with your parents and blah
blah blah and i just wish like
that's one of the things i wish i could
go back to certain parts
um j lawhead's back everybody
we're talking about uh going back to
school here by we i mean me and my
listeners who aren't talking
um and just saying things that you
missed are there any moments that you
wish you could go back to in school to
just have that [ __ ] comeback
you know when somebody gave you [ __ ] and
maybe beat the [ __ ] out of somebody or
maybe [ __ ] ask the girl out the
regrets
anything hmm that's a good question you
know what i one big regret i have is
that uh
my parents always said one of them
always took me to school that wasn't
cool
to what to watch because my parents were
all the way my dad was my heist my
senior
government teacher
oh my god i rolled into with my the high
school with my i rolled into high school
with my dad every day
oh jesus
but there must have been some girl stuff
that was cute they did because my dad
all the girls taught my dad they like
there was a couple girls that like had
shrine to my dad he was kind of a good
looking guy for his age back then he had
the power you know how the guys when you
had the power jay's dad by the way is a
hall of fame high school basketball
coach great guy you met him but he he so
he had that unbelievable mystique but he
was also a sharp looking guy he was a
good dresser he's kind of like a pat
riley chuck daly of his era he was
always a sharp dresser um good head of
hair so there was one girl in my class i
won't name her because if she's
listening she's yeah don't never don't
name me no but she had like my i
i discovered this my junior year she had
a shrine of my dad because he was a
coach so there would be newspaper
articles or anything she cut out of like
our school paper she opened her locker
one day and there was a shirt like
pictures of him from the newspaper
pictures of him coaching pictures of him
from the thing like she was like what
did you seriously just like it was
creepy you know i'm kind of half him
yeah i'm like
that's gotta be worth a hand job
um i hope but um like so it was just
kind of creepy but i i think the one
thing is i was held back in the fifth
grade this is like kind of a joke i tell
um
because it's kind of troublemaker but
the thing was is like a little bit of
like a troublemaker not doing my work
getting in with the wrong crowd type
thing but the joke was drugs no no no i
was just like you know like uh you know
getting sent to the office a lot being
you know set in the corner i was fifth
grade i mean i wasn't doing drugs you
know i i got held back in first grade
but not because of me
my my brother
was gonna borderline get held back in
third grade
and then my dad why are you catching him
um no my dad just had this one for all
all for one kind of thing so we held
everybody back and then just felt like
boys are more aren't as mature as girls
they should be held back so we held all
of us back yeah that's part of why i was
like the maturity level of just being a
i was the youngest and you know what's
funny is i still completely [ __ ]
screwed up
in in high school dude i i actually went
back to my parents house a few years ago
and you know i was getting the last
remaining [ __ ] out of there and my
mother doesn't throw anything out and
she had some of my my report cards dude
i i made
just it was [ __ ] ridiculous
it was c's d's and we didn't have f's
they were called e's i don't know why
yeah i'd see those like c's d like like
the high water mark maybe was a solid c
and it was just d plus d minus d e e and
you're a smart guy huh you're a smart
guy i mean that's like interesting like
no you're a smart guy i mean you're a
genius but you're a smart guy
yeah
from what i know
and what i'm good at is being a loud
mouth [ __ ] idiot and somehow
thanks to this business i'm able to turn
that into a living but if i was in
anything else
um i i was always a good i i got a good
work ethic for my parents but i i
trust me dude i failed
at a lot of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
yeah i i just i just wanted to have fun
dude that's all i want to do i didn't
want to lie i didn't want to uh i didn't
want to work i i didn't mind working but
it had to be fun that's why i like
working in warehouses i like blue-collar
jobs because there was this thing where
you were working but you weren't in like
this office of this cubicle you weren't
in this designated area it switched you
had different job sites and everybody
was [ __ ] funny like i had a bunny of
mine he did construction and um
i went over to his job site one time and
dude they were the funniest
[ __ ]
and they had like catch phrases they had
this thing what they would do if anybody
bitched
they would just like someone be like you
know what the [ __ ] is my nail gun i blah
blah you hear somebody all the other
side of the house just go
and do like this baby thing that this
wag thing and that's what they would
because what they were doing was this
unbelievable it was a [ __ ] [ __ ] of a
job so what it is
you just saw how humor worked because if
he starts bitching everybody [ __ ]
then you're just doing this job and you
got this negative thing so it was this
way
because anybody would do it they would
start [ __ ] laugh everybody else would
start [ __ ] laughing you'd be in 90
degree heat putting a [ __ ] roof on a
house
just hating your life dude i mean one
time
i i lasted i lasted 10 days doing this
[ __ ] before i went back to the
warehouses i was [ __ ]
uh working with these guys and we were
putting a roof on something and i had to
put like the the scaffolding like the
supports up drilling holes in and [ __ ]
you know hang on the side of the house
so they could put the board across it so
they could do the [ __ ]
the roof and i remember next door
was this house with a backyard with an
in-ground pool and these two [ __ ] hot
chicks are bringing out [ __ ] and these
two guys [ __ ] jersey shore looking
guys
laying out
right and enjoying their [ __ ] summer
and i was just sitting there going like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this picture
and i remember one of them at one point
was looking up watching us work and like
he was just one of those good-looking
shredded guys so he didn't have a
[ __ ] ounce of guilt
not announcing where i would actually in
shame
gone back into the house like i don't
want to be enjoying the pool with those
guys working like that they this guy was
just [ __ ] like if you would have
turned on the radio louder dude you
would have felt like we were making the
roof for him he just [ __ ] owned it
and i'll tell you that guy he has no
regrets from his childhood he crushed uh
you just see it this guy's crushing
everything he was this is [ __ ]
beautiful guy that's funny i still
remember that and there was this irish
guy billy you must work quicker you must
work quicker and at one point i got mad
it's like dude this is the first time i
[ __ ] ever put these up if you want me
to go faster and you've landed on your
[ __ ] back i'll do it you know
you know
i've never had a real job
that's one of the one thing i've loved
about my life so far is i've never had
one of those jobs where you just hate
every day like you know going into i've
always worked in the restaurants or you
know hard like hard labor worked out on
the highway crew worked out a little
construction more of a labor i didn't
know how to build anything right
carrying the ship but those kind of guys
you're right those kind of jobs are
where you meet really funny people that
you know appreciate the things that that
they get when they get them because
they're working their ass off dude you
know what you know one time like we we
had a guy
who worked and the guy was a total
[ __ ] alcoholic like coke head maniac
and one time he showed up
like i swear to god like he was supposed
to be the 8 30 showed up like 10 30 10
and he comes in all blurry died
and and his [ __ ] hair was soaking wet
from a shower and he just comes walking
and he goes all the traffic traffic was
driven
his [ __ ] hair
was soaking wet dude his eyes look like
road maps right he's big like it was
funny he had like this he was a big guy
but he never worked out it was just all
calories from his awful life and he had
this limp fish handshake he had skinny
arms and skinny legs and just this keg
of a chest and you know when those guys
just keep pushing the pants down and
tightening the belt
so he [ __ ] um
so we just used to keep giving him [ __ ]
this is before like being an alcoholic
was considered like a sad disease
so i remember we were going to get
donuts that day
and [ __ ] hilarious who go hey you
know paul you know i can't say i just
said his name paul paul you know what
you want uh you want anything from
donkeys we're going to dunkin donuts you
want anything you want to you know and
back then they had muffins they had they
had donuts and that type of [ __ ] and he
just goes that and somebody goes how
about a doughnut no good muffin no good
cop and i'm good and then this other guy
goes how about a rum cake
we all [ __ ] laughed our asses off of
the guy long story short he finally ends
up getting fired
and he left one of his
remember this remember shackets
it was like a it was a jacket and a
shirt
it was basically like a flannel shirt
with like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yes it
had the yeah yeah shack it so he left
that thing behind and this one dude you
talk about like a funny bastard and like
but really like artistic he took all
these empty boxes and made like a giant
statue of the guy out of the boxes and
he put the jacket on and he drew these
bleary eyes and he put like this mop and
thing on top dude we [ __ ] came in
even the boss
we were [ __ ] howling at this drunk
that we didn't even try to help we just
fired fired the guy sent him out on the
street and then we just made that we
laughed our asses off
and we left it up for like [ __ ] like
like this shrine it was up for like two
weeks and then finally the boss was just
so we'll run low on boss boxes
you gotta [ __ ] take that thing down
dude we had this other guy
i feel bad about this one this guy we
hired this guy in and the boss thought
it would be a good idea to hire somebody
that was a little bit older to try to
get some sort of [ __ ] maturity
because dude we we we just did all this
dumb [ __ ]
like uh you didn't care about your job
you just did dumb [ __ ]
and we had like these things that we
would do to get through the day i
remember there was
this guy hey what bin is this thing in
and it was it was 7 37
and he kept going 7 37 and the guy what
what and he finally jumped off these
boxes and did like this karate thing
went wow
7 37. as loud as he could and then one
day we just decided we were all going to
scream that at the same time and the
door was open from the warehouse into
the suited area where everyone was
dressed like michael j fox
and out of nowhere
and if it was just really quiet summer
day the entire warehouse screamed at the
top of their lungs just went whoa
7 37 right
and i'm around [ __ ] picked it's so
stupid i don't know why we did it picked
his [ __ ] head up and his boss
immediately came running in and he's
going they're yelling
they're yelling out here like like we
were animals like what are they doing
and then he got [ __ ] i almost said
balled out this is how old this story is
remember that expression
he got yelled at and then he came out
and he he had this high-pitched voice
and he'd be like you know come on you
guys you know you're right yeah blah
blah and then whenever he would talk we
would just do this impression of him
back we wouldn't even listen
we would just be going come on come on
you guys i love the trunks then he would
just be frustrated and would walk away
shaking his head and would just be like
a bunch of babies just a bunch of babies
and we we wouldn't listen
to anybody like the level of mad that he
had to get because he oh that's right
because he's a substitute no he used to
be us and then he got promoted ah there
you go and then that one and that was
that's what it was like i've often
wondered how bill russell was able to
coach his players even though they all
won together and he was the legend he
had a lot you know nine rings at that
point ten rings before he got his 11th
like there's just something about like
dude you're telling me to run the stairs
now give me a [ __ ] break exactly that
that's where yeah come on
all right let me i gotta read one more
advertising here my little more paul
harvey thing here and then i gotta go uh
good day
good day what do we got here is this it
uh we got a couple here all right
ladies
and gentlemen uh e-voice if you're an
entrepreneur and a customer calls do you
want to seem like you're in a high-rise
window view fancy-pants office or do you
want them to know you're sitting in your
underwear with e-voice you can create
the appearance of an entire building
sales customer support tech support you
name it they're going to think you got a
giant office uh give your customers the
royal treatment with e-voice e-voice
will forward business calls to your home
mobile or any number you choose wherever
you are e-voice will find you don't have
time to take a call no problem it's
routed to your voicemail and you can
read it at your convenience as an email
e-voice not only gives you an edge over
competitors it takes away the edge that
big companies have over you right now
why because you can appear that you're
just as big as they are and now you can
try evoice for 30 days for free go to
evoice.com use the promo code bill
that's evoice.com promo code bill bill
or just go to the podcast page for
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner
last but certainly not least
legal zoom everybody most americans do
not have a will but why
i don't know because they don't have a
pot to piss in yeah that's why i don't
have a will that's what i would guess
but if you do if you do it if you do
have a pot and it is filled with piss
you don't want government rules
dictating what happens to you to your
property and your minor children a lot
of people have children here we go this
is why so why procrastinate most people
say it's too expensive too time
consuming i don't want to do it my
answer is legalzoom.com too expensive
you're going to love legalzooms
responsible prices too time-consuming i
love these questions most people finish
the online process in just 20 minutes
and we're not just talking some fill in
the blank form your will is a state
specific purse and personalized based on
your information best of all legalzoom
has 12 years of experience helping
people with important legal matters uh
it's national make a will month
everybody every month is i get to i've
been saying this for three months uh so
don't wait any longer go to
legalzoom.com today and get 15 off your
last will but this offer ends soon or
get a legal trust and you'll receive a
power over will absolutely free
um to get your special discount be sure
to enter bur in the referral box at
checkout for wills powers of attorney
and trust and more go to legalzoom.com
legalzoom can provide self-help services
at your specific direction
or connect you with attorneys but they
are not a legal law firm there we go you
know what i think i just read
advertising from last month i i like how
they
basically
i like how that basically like
they say everything in a roundabout way
of basically saying please don't trash
my advertisers do it before you oh wait
wait they're basically saying do it
before you're done i wasn't supposed to
read legal stuff that i messed up so
they got a free one in there that's good
you know that's why i keep saying it's
national make a will month yeah who
really no i didn't uh well there's
always something like i remember one
time i was in atlanta and it was it was
national blueberry pancake day
you know from the people who bring you
blueberries comes blueberry pancake day
it's just like it's like naming a star
except there's only 365.
all right let's let's move on here where
are we in the podcast oh by the way
how's the uh oh she's looking good did
you peek oh yeah
just peeked she's looking good there's a
little look right okay we're right at
275. well i wanted to make sure that the
chips were you know needed any we you
know we're hey we're adding you know
apple
soaked apple chips to this bad boy we're
smoking them oh what did you start with
the apple do you start with the apple
yeah just sprinkle we're gonna get some
victory in there yeah i want to smoke
back in we're back in it with some
hickory yeah don't don't give me uh the
coors light of smoked [ __ ] pig but no
uh all right
need to stop being a nervous [ __ ] this
is gonna be the last one here people uh
billy redface love the podcast oh
speaking of red face the red state tour
it got splintered because of the acting
work so
this but no but i i'm making up all of
them so this week is gonna be uh
boulder and pike's peak on wednesday and
friday thursday we have off dum dum dum
dum
going to the uh broncos ravens game
my buddy in vegas this weekend he wanted
me to ask you he goes
because you know when you under the
disguise i'm from cleveland everybody
originally if you haven't known that but
the funny thing is when i told my boys
this weekend i was going to the broncos
ravens game they're like what is the guy
not like you because you know the ravens
are the browns and the broncos like put
it in our heart like nine times but you
got you guys
oh but no but it has nothing to do with
that's the actual cleveland brown
franchise at this point you just hate
the ravens well because of the browns
yeah originally because they're the
brown sure gorgeous yeah we still hate
them because of that that's why we hate
them and they're in our division and
they they they
win a super bowl twice and
you know what i mean there that's that's
does does ozzy newsome still work for
them yeah that's the problem he's the
only guy that went with modell and he's
been running that team and he had just
gotten the job like he we he was the
next player he had just gotten the job
as president of football operations when
we were in cleveland they leave town he
goes he they got two super bowls do you
know why you you guys never get
you i don't know if you would want the
attention
because i live through it it sucks you
don't want to be like oh the sports
misery capital of the world the reason
why you guys don't get the attention is
because you're not rivals with new york
city i think that that's why
we got what we did because uh it was
yankees red sox and then like
well you know what it was brown's gonna
get a little bit of that because we're a
steeler rival well we're not
even considered a rivalry anymore the
pittsburgh doesn't even worry about us
but we we the browns specifically do
kind of have that moniker in the nfl
kind of realm because of that steeler
rivalry and they've won six
but you know what's crazy is if you go
back and count nfl championships and
super bowls combined we still have more
we have seven nfl championships and i
think it's so [ __ ] ridiculous that
they don't count nfl championships
because the green bay packers are the
yankees of football oh yeah and they've
they've won in all areas they had a
rough the 70s and 80s were rough for
them
all right when the lin dickey yeah years
but even then they had james lofty at
one point they had james lofton and john
jefferson and they had nobody to throw
the ball to one of the worst moves
a player ever made john jefferson said
he went from the san diego chargers air
corial with dan fouts dan fouts and he
signed for more money
to play in frozen [ __ ] green bay it
wasn't lynn dickey at that point i
forget who what was the magic now before
the magic man
whoever the [ __ ] they had in between
there they just they just went through a
bad period yeah and um
he said he said if i stayed in san diego
uh jerry rice would be breaking all my
records and i'm telling you
he wasn't lying no no doubt
he was he was unreal him and i remember
wes chandler oh west west chandler in
that strike here where the redskins won
it he [ __ ] uh
he still had over a thousand yards
that's how much they were throwing it
you know those guys only played like 12
games didn't they
less than that dude they played like
eight or nine eight or nine the the the
i want to say the redskins were like
eight and one that year yeah cause the
scrubs played like four of them right or
whatever they call them oh is that that
year the the scabs scabs
yeah that kind of thing something that i
find fascinating is just how like
certain teams just
they they get new coaches they get new
owners and blah blah but they just still
there's this thing where they just
like the giants will always just have a
great defense
the bears always have a good defense but
they for the life of them the bears have
never had a superstar quarterback ever
even jim mcmahon jim mcmahon was a
personality he was like he was like the
guy
the downtown julie brown of quarterbacks
right like more like like a socialite
yeah i would put him he couldn't jump
he couldn't carry you on his back in the
fourth quarter like an elway or a
montana he wasn't that kind of they've
never had that cleveland otto graham
maybe was your last superstar bernie was
tough man oh bernie closer was good i
mean but yeah really i mean we had a
frank ryan a lot of people brian
people forget frank grant brian stipe
won an mvp in 81 almost won it again in
82. um
frank ryan was great frank ryan i
believe
through brian's site rick springfield
same guy
i'm telling you same guy one in my head
when i think of him
frank ryan though a lot of people don't
realize i think frank ryan has the
greatest winning percentage of any
starting quarterback in the history of
the nfl he came after otto graham but he
was winning paul brown they were still
winning tigers like just winning titles
left and right all the time
and we had bill belichick for one year
last time we won a playoff game
the last time we won a beat
we beat the new england patriots and
bill belichick was our coach yeah the
last time 94 i was at that game wild
card game in cleveland stadium the last
time we have won a playoff we beat we
who do you like uh what do you like uh
what do you think peyton manning west
welker
i love that man
veterans that's like stable i think
we're gonna see of like a 45-38
thursday night i think so yeah flacco
they can play dude baltimore's gonna put
up some points this year they're gonna
have to because that defense ain't gonna
be as good as it used to be
we're gonna see a ball game yeah but is
flacco that good placo is that good you
think he can put out numbers like that
i'm not saying he's not a good
quarterback because i think he's a good
question i didn't believe in him forever
and i was wrong that playoff run man i
think that played but then showed it but
is he like
he's gonna go [ __ ]
touchdown for touchdown against manny
well
i mean maybe not all season long but in
this game you know what's funny about
manning is like everybody was looking
like he's a little fragile china doll
and now now that he made the season
nobody's even thinking about it like he
keep one hit they were showing his
spinal cord this guy could never walk
again and now nobody's nobody's talking
about it
some of them are predicting him to win
the mvp award this year longest neck
sense uh steve brogan
martin hanks is another name steve
grogan too steve grogan had to wear like
two neck braces just to pile them up
yeah well they have they have all that
flesh between the shoulder pad and the
helmet yeah like two or three of them
just stopped on top of each other we'll
see i think they're gonna have they're
gonna oh this is my prediction on uh uh
tim tebow
tim tebow's gonna get cut and he's gonna
go to the cfl he's gonna become a
superstar up there like doug flutie did
and he's going to come back the end of
his career either with buffalo with the
bears really that's my prediction you
think he's going to the cfl cfl yes sir
you heard it here today on monday
morning podcast yeah he'll be able to be
able to run around because like it's
that feels like 100 yards in both
directions right or meters whatever the
[ __ ] they say it's 110 long and i think
60 wide
did see see what i'm saying just when
you guys thought i was a sports fan this
is why i go to him he [ __ ] knows
everything all right need to stop being
a nervous [ __ ] billy redface love the
podcast uh as soon as i have
a need for any of the services that are
advertising your show i'll make sure i
go there so thank you um this may not
rake jesus get to the [ __ ] point
i'm dying a slow death working a day job
that isn't fun anymore
the money's great i'm 32 and make a mid
six figure salary but like you i'm not
really motivated by more money i would
much rather
okay i dream on a daily basis he wrote
that all on capital letters about doing
comedy full-time
all right jay this guy's making mid-six
figures
he's 32 years old i'll trade you
[Music]
you can have i got i got 45 minutes you
can take it right now give me the mid
six figures i'm gone uh stand up
improv sketch performing writing
producing i'd love to do it all i'd love
to do it all all the time but the flip
side of not being motivated by more
money is being motivated by the fear of
not having enough see i'm a nervous [ __ ]
as you would say
well dude once you're making mid six
figures and you're 32 years old you're
not nervous you're you're also kind of
rational
okay
you like that's why you try and start as
young as you can because you're stepping
off a curb rather than a [ __ ]
three-story building at this point that
you own and have tenants in
um i didn't start talking 31. yeah no no
no absolutely and what's his face
retired
um dangerfield and he came back i'm not
discouraging the guy i'm just saying
that he's not but i wasn't making
six figures i don't think i would have
jumped off the curb for that right but
he he's look
he he's he's he's not nervous that's
what i'm saying he's thinking rationally
so anyways
he goes see i'm a nervous [ __ ] as you
would say with the new jersey mortgage
aka the land of high taxes bills and a
three-year-old daughter i can't bring
myself to cut and run from the corporate
country i work in my wife and i have no
debt other than the mortgage dude that's
great that's great man and we generally
live below our income level that's also
great those are two things you need to
do which people don't do anymore in the
country you really need to do that man
uh but i don't think we live at or below
the income
that we'd have if i stopped killing
myself on a daily basis by commuting
to a [ __ ] computer instead of
commuting to a couch with a laptop and a
giant cup of coffee just to work on
comedy ship i love [ __ ] i love how he's
he's romanticizing being a comedian yeah
although he's kind of right
um
it's more coming out your pajamas with a
hangover
trying to figure out how to get that
[ __ ] whatever you picked up that
night out of your hotel room
and then going downstairs and having a
greasy breakfast to [ __ ] i don't know
anyways i have no frame of reference to
know how much money could be made or how
long it would take to make it and i'm
scared shitless that i don't have the
talent or the balls or both to actually
get paid to make people laugh in spite
of believing in
all right my friends tell me to practice
practice comment [ __ ] dude i can get
right to the end of this all right this
is what you got to do
you do both
don't quit your [ __ ] job
this is what you do write five minutes
of material and go sign up for an open
mic and try stand-up comedy
okay
that way if you go up and you eat your
[ __ ] balls and you hated it and it
was humiliating and you don't ever want
to do it again you're not going to be
sitting at your cubicle going what if
you're going to be like no i tried it i
i
bombed and i didn't like it now
if you go down there
and you go up
and
even if you bomb
but you still like it
you know which is a major [ __ ]
sign if you bomb and you still like i
want to come back then just keep coming
back
and keep doing that and just balancing
it out and i but i you need to have a
major talk with your wife and just say
listen this is going to kill me if i
never try this i but i promise to you i
promise you that there's going to be no
let down me as a husband or a father
here
but there will be you know a couple of
nights
a month at first just to see i just have
to know
okay
and um
then if she goes well you're making mid
six figures and
that's when you start pointing out all
the morons that you listen to on
podcasts that are making [ __ ] money
in this business okay and i'm telling
you dude if i can do it anybody can
[ __ ] find a place
uh well not anybody you know what i mean
if you have any sort of [ __ ] talent
you can do it jay i've watched you there
is one thing i'd like to say real quick
before you say that because he's
mentioned money a couple times like he's
like and then i don't know i don't have
any frame of reference about how much
money i could make if i could make any
order
the one thing is you can't i don't think
you can worry about that going into it
because
you know you see them every day in the
clubs in l.a and everywhere else within
five or seven years you could be a
millionaire and then you know what five
or seven years after that nobody wants
to work you i mean because it's a it's a
it's like that but then and that's
that all goes down to what he was
talking about and it goes all down to
that living within your means paying
down your house not carrying credit card
debt like dude
these [ __ ] people
doesn't mean that you don't feel smart
doing you're not killing and then still
not this people could die in five years
after you were making a million you know
what i mean right business in this
business but there's people in the nfl
in the nba and in show business with
their own tv shows living paycheck to
paycheck because they're doing the exact
same [ __ ] thing that you do just at a
much grander scale and everybody goes
how the [ __ ] could you [ __ ] that up and
you know most people saying that are
doing it at that lev at their level now
it's look if you're not making any
[ __ ] money i get living paycheck to
paycheck but if
you know you don't need that extra pair
of sneakers you don't need another flat
screen tv you don't even need a [ __ ]
tv there's ways you got to get out in
front of it yeah if when you're young
you got to start building up a [ __ ]
nest egg and you gotta
get on the internet read some books
figure out
how [ __ ] evil the game is so you at
least know how it's played so you can
like take on as little water as you can
and you can [ __ ] stay afloat because
because
you know
there's a lot of people want to do other
things and that they just got a ball and
chain around their [ __ ] neck
and it financially and they just got
themselves in this thing so if you're in
that situation just immediately start
[ __ ]
dude i would have a yard sale and just
start selling [ __ ] downsizing my life
and if i had to take two years off from
[ __ ]
living the american dream and just
paying myself down and getting out of
that [ __ ] debt i would do it and i
would start over again because that [ __ ]
will [ __ ] keep me up at night and i
mean this guy talks like he's like you
know he is getting his money everything
but but what i'm saying is like
just be aware of the idea of the money
of it isn't why because
you maybe
making make making mid six figures and
what he's doing 95 percent of the times
you can't go backwards usually well
probably what he does for a living once
he hits 150 a year the next step is 165
to 200 here that's not the formula in
stand-up comedy you can make 150 two
three years in a row and guess what by
year four you're making 45. no but this
is the great thing about stand-up comedy
though is or you can make two million no
but what's great about stand-up comedy
though is you're never unemployed true
you're never unemployed
you're never employed unless no but
unless you you want to uh unless your
ego gets in the way where like say you
know you were selling
selling out clubs you know so you're
just coming in doing thursday through
saturday i'm not doing the sunday show
if it starts to taper off and they want
you to do the sunday show and you refuse
to do it you start doing that [ __ ]
rather than being like i got to get it
going again then then you can get
yourself some [ __ ] trouble but like
um
you know i don't know how actors do it i
don't know how musicians do it that
shit's [ __ ] hard being a stand-up
comic once you start
you know you've established yourself
you've made a name for yourself if you
never take your foot off the gas pedal
and you just keep pushing yourself and
you keep doing that like you you can
have the closest thing
to job security but even in his world
dude like they could downsize they
should [ __ ] kick him out and then
then he's at that weird age so dude this
is my advice don't quit your job but i
would definitely just start doing it and
there's nothing wrong if you
always keep your job and you just do
stand up because you like doing it or
you start a sketch group with your
friends and just have fun um and don't
listen to any other comedians who are
saying like you're taking my stage time
it isn't their stage time all right it's
an art it doesn't belong to anybody it
it's supposed to make you happy and
other people happy when you do it so
that that's what i would do
all right so good luck to you sir you're
not a nervous [ __ ] okay you're a [ __ ]
normal human being stop being hard on
yourself so there you go there's the
podcast for this week um like i
mentioned
uh me and jason lawhead we're gonna be
at the boulder theater and uh boulder i
believe that's the name of it i can't
even wait to say that word when i get
there isn't that the great that's like a
voiceover's dream is boulder that can go
from like a beer commercial
all the way to like a murder mystery
show like
in that quiet town of boulder
it was murder or you could be like you
know when we were rockies with cold
water or boulder you know like you ever
watched it you ever watched that [ __ ]
when they'd sit there and uh i love
those murder mystery shows yeah and they
said that guy just goes you know just be
like
it was a quiet town that's my dream
the gazebo yeah they had fourth of july
but the underbelly i want to do that
every day
that's what you do but on that
night
the town turned to murder you know i
love that stuff dude this wasn't
supposed to happen in this town
a town where they keep the doors
unlocked at night yeah
you knew your neighbor
people sat on porches drinking tulip
yeah boulder's the perfect name for oh
that's a voiceover
boulder colorado september 4th
pikes peak center colorado springs on
the sixth look for me and jason where uh
we're going to be looking for a tailgate
if you guys have any information if you
got if you throw it down and you do it
right
and you got some extra brisket or
something uh and i'll be cheering for
the broncos because all the years i
cheered against them when they were
playing the actual browns now they're
playing the old browns who are in my
division and i will i will definitely be
cheering for the broncos because i've
been so mean to peyton manning over the
years and now you get that thing where
you're getting sentimental because he's
in the final third
and then you you know that's like dr j i
didn't hate him as much magic
same with me with michael jeter i hated
jordan because he killed us and then as
he got older i'm like i'm going to miss
that guy yeah i'm just saying that guy
yeah
dude if lebron they're talking about
lebron he ain't coming back to cleveland
no going to the lakers oh wait it was a
joke over there dude if he goes to the
lakers and that championship is
celebrated then you know what i want you
know what you know what they should do
they should literally have like
the pre-game for that should literally
be like eighth graders playing first
graders in tackle football
and then doing long
[ __ ] interviews with the eighth
graders when they won talking about
coming together as a team and all that
type of [ __ ] i'm telling you dude like
to go to the lakers when we're some
stupid number like 49 or something you
know what i mean like you know just like
it'll be just the worst
it's what sports is becoming and you
know what i saw some [ __ ] who was
trying to say that pylon teams are not
a new thing
it was so dumb like he's trying to sit
there saying like talking about like
those laker teams in the 80s and celtics
like dude those teams were built
built yeah through trades and drafts
it wasn't like magic and james worthy
sat on a yacht during the off season
going hey man would it be great if we
all played in the same team [ __ ]
[ __ ] the guy this guy had the top 10
sports myths and he tried to say that
that was his but pylon teams were a
sportsman it wasn't and go back and look
at the teams that didn't win it in those
eras
that were built the i watched the nba
hardwood classics a couple weeks ago
they had the 1985 all-star game on the
milwaukee bucks had four guys on the
eastern all-stars they won seven
straight seven straight 50-win seasons
all built through the draft in trades
and this is what the guy was saying
though his justification that they were
pile on teams despite the fact nobody
piled on
was that in the in the 80s
the lakers the celtics the sixers and
the pistons were the only ones who won
championships everybody else was without
he goes so it was it was good for the
league and that's and it's complete
[ __ ] because what they didn't
realize was that despite the fact that
the bucks never came through they had
sydney moncrieff jack sigma terry
cummings jackson paul presley what
jackson was on that was on the uh the
science before but no he came to the
bucks in the mid mid-80s sonic's he was
in uh he was uh uh
um
he came to the box back then back then
you had you had blockbuster trades yeah
like when moses malone went to the
sixers there would be an occasion or
where kareem went to the lakers but
there wasn't like
like what happened in boston we're just
overnight dude we went from the worst
team in the league to winning the
championship and we [ __ ] go
we got kevin garnett for nothing from
kevin mchale that should have been
investigated the same way the way the
lakers got uh uh pau gasol and jerry
jerry west was was with [ __ ] uh was
that who it was was with the [ __ ]
yeah uh grizzly grizzlies yeah like both
those trades were complete
behind enemy lines [ __ ] and then we
got ran right that's why i wasn't upset
when when ray went to miami i was like
well dude that's how we got him he
wasn't ours he wasn't a celtic he but i
still look at him like he's one of the
great the greats that played for the
organization but it's it's a different
thing
where he was like you become like a
mercenary like they're just they're
bringing you in
a couple weeks ago lebron had there was
this big news that he took he's going to
add another hour to the podcast i'll end
with this a couple weeks ago lebron had
this big news where he tweeted out his
top three players of all time i some big
publication tweeted at him like hey
lebron you've never talked about that
so everybody's like on the edge of their
c what's his big three so he named i'm
not going to be mad at the list in a way
because it's hard it's so subjective
three players really he said larry bird
which i thought that was pretty cool
bird's the greatest small forward in the
history of the game i don't know if i'd
put him on the greatest three list uh he
said uh michael jordan yeah that's great
that's easy and dr j i love dr j that's
great maybe that's he's not but how do
you i tweet back to him i go really can
how do you leave
kareem off the list i go to guy won six
titles one of which in milwaukee to boot
i go that's kind of like a guy winning
one in cleveland
oh
wow
that'd be like if somebody won one in
cleveland is what i said i said he won
one in milwaukee to boot how many have
they won since that'd be like somebody
one and one in cleveland that's what i
tweeted out
jesus christ very clever way of saying
well thank you thanks for leaving buddy
exactly so i i i like dr j because i
love that this is why because big thing
with me is changing the game yes and
like that's fine and i'm fine with that
yeah i'm not mad at his list i'm just
saying how do you leave kareem off cream
change what what what did well let's see
if i only had three i would have to pick
three guys who changed the game so it
would be jordan it would be dr j
and then i would have to be somebody
else that i i'm not aware of from the
60s like uh russell i mean i mean you
could ask was it oscar robinson who's
got all the points yeah yeah oscar was
great i mean people don't realize how
great bob pettit was i mean bob pettit
was a i know that there's somebody from
that era because that's that's one of
those things
with like stand up where you had like
like what lenny bruce did
took it to first of all you had the
vaudeville guys whoever the first guys
to do that then you have lenny bruce did
then you had what pryor did and what
prior did i feel is like what jordan did
was there's just some guys they their
genius is at such a level that it's
you can't surpass it yeah it's they
almost take it to the end i would say
like james brown james brown
the the music that he made there's been
a zillion funk bands after him but
nobody ever took it to another level
changed the game yeah never and i still
think jeb barr i don't know how you can
leave jabar off any list he changed the
game he changed it he he he won six
titles magic never won one without i
didn't know oldest oldest player ever to
win
how did he change the game he changed
the game by well first off they outlawed
dunking right
but they did that will chamberlain
because of the nba too though no because
of uh they well
here's how he changed the game both ends
of the floor he was russell russell
couldn't do what jabbar did on the
offensive end you can say wilt
chamberlain yeah he was dominant but
because they've moved jabar away from
the basket chamberlain couldn't do
anything away from the basket jabar
developed the sky hook from 20 feet out
and he was ju he was russell on both
ends of the court and
russell couldn't play offensively like
jabar could not even close jabar the
fact that he won oldest man ever to win
a finals mvp award the guy won the nba
he won the nba finals mvp at 38. i mean
come on man in a young dude i'm not
arguing with you i just like karen like
seriously dude like what's the name of
your podcast by the wall heads court
yeah if you want to listen to a guy who
really knows sports as opposed to me
being brady anderson calling in tomorrow
former oriole brady anderson first guy
first guy to hit 50. so it should be an
interesting uh conversation i met brady
at the hollywood improv a few weeks ago
got him in because that's great dude you
remember you know dan godfrey from uh
irvine and probably dan big oreos man
yeah so i'm i'm ducking in there a
couple weeks ago because i hear hotels
in town so i was over at the store so i
ducked in i wanted to see david tell set
well the place is packed quick story
there's a line and you know the door guy
i know works at improv i'm just
squeezing by going like i'm gonna go to
the bar and try to peek my head in to
see hotel and there's this girl like
arguing with the door guys she's like my
friends are in there he's like i can't
let you in it's full she's like my
brother and i look over as i'm like
squeaking by i look and she's with brady
anderson i can pick out an athlete right
he ended his career as an indian and i
met him in cleveland one time just down
in the flats after a game he was a cool
guy so what'd you do so i was like so
she's arguing so i was just like hey man
how you doing he's like hey good i go
hey man i'm a fan i'm from cleveland
actually he's like oh cool man brady i'm
like chase he's like he's like and then
she goes she sees it she's like do you
know anybody here i'm like well i'm a
comic but i'm not working tonight she's
like can you help us get in i'm like
i don't know and i just dan godfrey is
now the like district manager but he's
never so did you get him in i just got
to end the podcast yeah i'm like adam
got him in he gave gives me his phone
number he's like anytime you want
tickets thanks for getting me in dude he
gives me his phone number he's like come
to baltimore so when can they hear them
one can hear them on the podcast they'll
be hearing them this thursday the
podcast will drop i'm interviewing them
tomorrow via phone it'll be this
thursday brady anderson man all right on
law heads court look for it jason law
every everybody gotta go check that pork
shoulder rose bowl tailgate legend
j lawhead just tripped over a box there
goes the legend part all right guys
thanks for listening have a happy labor
day go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to you
next week